قال مارك ريجيف كبير مستشاري رئيس الوزراء
الاسرائيلي بنيامين نتنياهو ان اسرائيل لم
تعلن مسؤوليتها عن هجوم بيروت الذي ادى
الى مقتل القيادي في حركه حماس صالح
العاروري واثنين من قاده القسام لكنه اضاف
في لقاء مع شبكه ام اس ام بي سي ان
اسرائيل تعاملت في السابق مع مستهدفين في
الخارج وان حكومه نتنياهو اكدت في السابق
ان كل المتورطين في عمليه السابع من
اكتوبر
المشروع لم تعلن اسرائيل مسؤوليتها واعتقد
ان علينا ان نكون واضحين فاسرائيل تعاملت
في الماضي مع الارهابيين في دول اجنبيه
واعتقد ان الحقيقه ستجدها عند رئيس
الوزراء ووزير الدفاع ورئيس هيئه الاركان
الذين قالوا ان كل شخص وكل قاده
الارهابيين المتورطين في قتل المدنيين
الاسرائيليين في مذبحه السابع من اكتوبر
ارهابيون وهدف مشروع وعلى كل من قتل
مواطنا اسرائيليا ان يتوقع ان تصل اليه
الدوله الاسرائيليه في نهايه المطاف لكن
هذا بيان عام لا علاقه له بالوضع الحالي
في بيروت وليس لدي تعليق
عليه